bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département le sommaire de votre
émission handball contre performance
pour les faits me de
montigny-le-bretonneux dans le
championnat de national
une saisie montanes ont perdu sur leur
teint contre pessac et les détails dans
ce magazine vox l'élan courtois a dit la
môme a dit champion d'europe des poids
super-moyens depuis mai 2015 s'est
incliné à liverpool contre le
britannique adam smith contredit le
premier en rade il n a pas réussi à se
remettre d'une contre attaque de
l'anglais nous le recevrons dans
quelques instants sur ce plateau pour
s'appuyer la 22e édition de la glu en
courses étaient programmées ce week-end
au départ du gymnase des droits de
l'homme à guyancourt plus de 350
coureurs se sont inscrits pour la
compétition retour sur cette épreuve
dans cette édition
et puis nous parlerons football nous
recevrons dans quelques instants
l'équipe senior de plaisir les plaisirs
oies sont actuellement à la troisième
place du classement de première division
de district
nouvelle défaite pour les féminines de
montigny-le-bretonneux lésigny montaigne
se sont inclinés contre bessac des sacs
et à domicile sur le score de 22 à 21
conséquence les joueuses de bruno
philippe se dirige tout droit vers la
descente en nationale 2 en fin de saison
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude troisième défaite consécutive
pour les féminines de montigny le
bretonneux dans le championnat de
national
une les vertes et loire se sont inclinés
dans les dernières secondes contre le
stade pessacais à domicile le score 22 à
terrible déception effectivement car on
avait on avait préparé ce match en temps
mot sur une équipe de pessac peut-être
un petit peu plus objective c'est à dire
on a beaucoup cherché des solutions
visuel dans des situations on aurait dû
jouer un petit peu plus collectif contre
le stress vous savez les filles me
stresse vous savez quand vous êtes à la
dernière place
petit peu compliqué d'être parfois de
faire preuve d'objectivité un petit
coussin
le tournant du match la blessure de la
capitaine de montigny fanny jean
baptiste en milieu de deuxième période
la blessure de fanni déjà nous fait mal
c'est vrai parce qu'on perd on perd bas
celle qui marqué le plus de buts c'est
notre capitaine
fanny est une joueuse qui est connu
comme do de la vidéo ils ont vu voilà
ils se sont coupés d'hab
malheureusement c'est un petit peu un
petit peu dur pour nous après cette
défaite les hypothèses restent derrière
du classement à sept journées de la fin
du championnat à un point du premier non
relégable l'as ergué noir tant que
mathématiquement c'est possible on y
croit voilà on manque encore
d'expérience on est novice en inde en
mai mais on a fait quelque chose
aujourd'hui on sait quand même battu et
on a montré quelque chose est certaine
ce qui est important c'est à la fin du
spectacle compagne les artistes comme on
dit par chez nous à tarnos midi là bas
et il reste encore des matches à jouer
on va les jouer vous pouvez compter sur
nous prochain match pour les féminines
de montigny le bretonneux le samedi 16
avril sur le terrain d'aulnay
après le ballon passe à un autre sport
de contact la boxe l'élan courtois
d'ilham houmadi champion d'europe des
poids super moyens depuis à mai 2015
s'est incliné à liverpool liverpool
contre le britannique adam smith
contrées dès le premier rang de la dila
n'a pas réussi à se remettre d'une
contre attaque de l'anglais pour nous
parler de son combat
nous recevons le boxeur a dit lahm
houmadi sur ce plateau bonsoir adila
bonsoir alors un peu plus d'une semaine
après ce combat
comment vous sentez-vous très bien très
bien très bien enfants pour remonter sur
le ring il reprend des entraînements
alors venez on va revenir au combat
pourquoi avoir perdu ce combat qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait c'était c'était
une erreur dès le début du combat
je pense une erreur ou bon ça a été plus
ou moins une stratégie qui avait été
mise en place
un hack latine c'est vrai c'était couper
à distance et je suis quelqu'un aussi
qui aime qui bloque beaucoup à la
pression donc
ça a été un combat qui est qui est parti
a un impacte directement au contact et
bomba
le contre est passé de le contrer passé
j'ai reçu un contre et puis ça j'ai pas
eu la possibilité de récupérer dessus ce
combat se joue sur ce coup là je pense
que je pense à essai était sur le contre
où j'ai pas spécialement pu récupérer et
puis il a bien saisi l'occasion et il a
mis son accélération et
et l'habitat a pu arrêter combat et je
pense a bien fait d'arrêter qu'on m'a
aussi et vous avez réussi quand même à
le contrer dans sa oui oui après c'était
sur les
les premiers échanges je pense que lui
attendait aussi simplement de boxer en
contre donc son travail
ap ir je pense aussi que vous avez senti
que ce combat allait se terminer très
rapidement non alors à l'aller où il a
commencé je me suis dit ben dans tous
les cas c'est pas un combat qui feraient
les 12 voilà c'est un combat c'était je
pense vous vouliez ou moi
avant le quatrième donc ce qu'on va se
terminer par arrêt de l'arbitré a eu
raison d'arrêter ce combat
alors qu'on est sur le
quand on est sur le ring peut-être pas
spécialement les mêmes questions mais
c'est vrai qu'avec un peu de recul je
pense que
larbitre raison d'arrêter je pense moi
j'aurais fait la même
vous étiez ko debout qui nous était
encore consciente et puis chiant il vous
tapez alors j'étais conscient c'est vrai
que c'est au niveau de la posture est
bon dans tous les cas il ya vu qu'ils
avaient pas eu de riposte la rabbits et
c'est ça il ya un à deux temps ou si on
répond pas et arrêtent au combat qu'adam
smith est si fort qu'on le dit je te
rappel pour les téléspectateurs il a
gagné 19 combats sur 19 il ya réalisé 14
k o
ouais il est si fort qu'on le dit où ils
étaient prenables non non non il était
il est prenable
il est prenable c'est je pense
maintenant il a saisi sa chance au même
titre que j'aurais pu la saisir
sur la stratégie que j'avais mis en
place sur la sienne s'est passé elle
savait et elle a été à viry bonne et
puis la miette bon bah c'était aussi le
côté qui peut qui pourra être frustrant
de ma part de ne pas avoir pu
mais justement toute cette stratégie en
place et ne pas avoir vu justement ce
dont j'étais capable de faire face à
kaboul speed
vous avez été trop rapide fait dans le
combat vous avez voulu finir trop
rapidement peut-être seconds n'ont pas
pas forcément finir trop rapidement
c'était l'objectif n'était pas finir
trop rapidement parce que j'ai je me
suis préparé pour pouvoir faire 12
drones tenir douze ondes
donc ce n'était pas le but n'était pas
de finir avant maintenant en boxe on
sait que
ça peut arriver tout peut arriver un
contre peut terminer un combat on peut
mener 10 ou 12 drones et sur le dernier
dernier round perdre sur un contre qu'on
n'a pas vu venir où arrivait le fait que
ce combat soit en angleterre ça a joué
peut-être dans votre tête
ah non du tout ils ont eu du tout du
tout qu'on soit en angleterre ou si on
avait été à pareille s'arrêter là même
j'ai pensé assez préparé pour ce combat
gt gt à 100% j'étais à 100% j'étais à
100% maintenant je pense simplement que
oui c'est ce nom ça a été une question
de stratégie maintenant larbitre arrêté
bas
tant mieux c'est pas j'ai pas
spécialement subi sur sordide rooney
puis non c'est ça a été un acte en tout
cas ça va ça ça va être une très belle
expérience pour moi ça a été une belle
expérience
et puis j'ai tenté de mettre en place ce
que je savais faire
c'est tout a dit là vous avez 35 ans oui
est ce qu'après ce combat votre carrière
est terminée où elle va encore continuer
encore pendant des années un nom alors
ma carrière n'est pas terminée
il faut le savoir n'est pas terminé ma
carrière je suis assez vrai call à votre
carrière
alors elle va peut-être un peu plus
retardée parce que finalement ce qui
était mis en place était jeu le
vainqueur du combat remporté
les ceintures et remporter un
championnat wbc du mois une finale wcc
demi finales pour un problème c'était
pour accéder au championnat du monde
maintenant je pense que
la team du mois les promoteurs qui
s'occupe du mois de ma carrière vont
mettre en place à un futur combat qui me
remettrai des raids dans les classements
pour de nouveaux ray reparti ip à un
titre
aussi important que ce que j'ai pu faire
samedi dernier cas vous allez repartir
avec le même staff
ah oui on change pas une équipe qui
gagne on change pas une équipe qui gagne
ça peut arriver
jade et fait pas arriver maintenant je
pense qu'elle est plus grands champions
pu avoir
ar ont pu être aussi dans la situation
que j'ai pu être ça me dit samedi
dernier il faut simplement pas baisser
les bras je ne baisse pas les bras j'ai
un objectif en tête et mon but sera de
le réaliser
voilà de pouvoir entrer ou faire un
monde un championnat du monde vous avez
déjà une date prochain combat
oui ça va être normalement normalement
et
en fin juillet je crois quelque chose
comme ça c'est l'auteur en tout cas
voilà merci à vous voulez passer sur ce
plateau on continuera à suivre vos
exploits du coup sûr sur tv fil 78 la
merveille dans le 7-8 sport après la
boxe on passe à la course à pied c'est
une tradition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la 22e édition
de la glu en courses étaient programmées
ce week-end au départ du gymnase des
droits de l'homme à guyancourt plus de
350 coureurs se sont inscrits pour la
compétition roma reste finit à pour le
montage ce dimanche 10 avril les runner
sont venus en nombre à guyancourt il
était 387 inscrit à la 22e édition de la
nuit en course
la compétition est organisée comme
chaque année par l'entente athlétique de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une course qui est vraiment à
portée locale les coureurs viennent de
saint quentin en yvelines bien sûr
puisque c'est un rendez vous attendu à
50 1 mais viennent aussi du département
voire des départements limitrophes hauts
niveaux catégorie on au registre
aujourd'hui une personne qui a plus de
90 ans
pour ce 10 km les spectateurs ont eu le
droit à un duel de haute voltige
françois l'acquis qui travaillent à
montigny le bretonneux s'est imposé en
34 minutes et 17 secondes
le sportif a devancé de 9 secondes le
robot lite alain jarry on essaie de
courir en tête la moitié de la course
après ça s'est joué sur la seule
difficulté de là quasiment de la journée
dans la fameuse côte entre les deux
étangs et là il est un petit peu coincé
et après l'écart s'est fait et j'essaie
de maintenir belle course je tiens à
féliciter le premier il a fait une belle
course il est parti au bon moment dans
la côte
voilà je connaissais pas trop le
parcours donc je n'ai pas osé partir
avec lui et je pense avoir bien fait
parce qu'il était quand même très solide
et mérite sa victoire du félicite alain
jarry pourrait prendre sa revanche en
2016 les deux runner devrait s'aligner
l'année prochaine sur la 23e édition de
la guye en course
bon jouer ce week-end la 19e journée du
championnat de première division de
district l'équipe senior de plaisir a
perdu ce week-end sur le terrain de
bailly noisy à l'extérieur le score 2
buts 1 pour lui parler de ce match du
classement du club nous recevons sur ce
plateau le directeur sportif tony à
salamone l'entraîneur mathieu à bollée
da et melchior kasongo capitaine de
l'équipe senior bonsoir alors cette
défaite est elle logique au vu du match
non je ne pense pas que cette défaite
était logique
on a dominé toute la première mi temps
on a même eu des occasions de marquer on
a lui même eu un penalty qui nous aurait
fait du bien si on avait marqué le
premier but mais on n'a pas réussi à
marquer puis après en deuxième mi temps
on a eu un contre un mauvais un mauvais
geste
on a pris le premier but puis après on
s'est un petit peu énervé et un peu
déstabilisé donc on aurait dû marquer en
première mi-temps pour pour faciliter la
tâche mais on n'a pas su faire
menger vous êtes d'accord avec what
coach tout à fait mais c'est un problème
qui perdure depuis déjà pas mal de temps
mais vous avouerez s'est défait de jeu
il ya efficacement cette première
période sur lequel on tue pas moche
en deuxième période il y a effectivement
manque d'efficacité tant défensive qu
offensive qui a fait que effectivement
au final on sort avec une défaite de
busan donc je le rappelle vous avez eu
un penalty et sur l'engagement vous
allez vous allez prendre un but très
rapidement donc dix secondes après c'est
bien ça c'est rageant de prendre un but
aussi rapidement ne pas conserver du
coup bien évidemment d'autant plus que
sur l'action je pense qu'il ya une
petite faute mais après cassation de
leurs bêtes ils sont libres de leur
choix ils font
la proximité est joué vous êtes une
équipe qui marque beaucoup de buts vous
avez marqué 45 buts depuis le début du
championnat
vous êtes la deuxième meilleure attaque
du championnat sur ce match finalement
il n'y a pas eu peut-être d'automatismes
en attaque qu'ils ont fait est qu il
voit là vous auriez pu gagner c'est trop
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
manque d'efficacité dans le dernier
geste on doit tirer au tir au lieu de
centrer oms entre le tir et on
s'applique pas sur sur le sur le dernier
geste
ce qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à marquer
parce que les occasions secret donc
voilà manque d'efficacité offensive
c'est un match très rugueux on en
parlait précédemment très rugueux avec
beaucoup d'engagement
vous avez réussi à mettre assez
d'intensité pour remporter cette
rencontre
on avait beaucoup misé sur la première
mi temps qu'on avait mis deux attaquants
en point pour pour essayer de les gêner
pour essayer d'appuyer pour marquer le
très rapidement ce qu'on n'a pas réussi
à faire et après deuxième mi temps
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué nous
aurons répondu physiquement nous sommes
rentrés un peu dedans voilà et après le
but contre nous
tony il ya quand même du positif dans ce
type de rencontre moi je prends ma part
de la rencontre parce que aujourd'hui si
on est encore animé par un espoir de
montée bah c'était pas l'objectif
premier du club
donc quand on a mis en place le binôme
de jeune entraîneur qui va que sont
clément et mathieu on a pour leur a pas
donné comme objectif de monter donc
aujourd'hui qu'on tutoie la montée à
quelques journées de la fin pour moi
tant que directeur sportif c'était déjà
très positif donc il n'avait pas de
pression à outrance donc bon alors
aujourd'hui on a perdu c'est dommage
parce qu'effectivement on avait on a
vécu ça et dar es salaam
cette montée mathématiquement on va dire
que c'est possible mais c'est ça va
devenir extrêmement compliqué parce
qu'on a eu droit en a droit à aucun faux
pas maintenant et puis montini a quand
même un boulevard et bien ouvert et donc
je pense que sur l'ensemble de la saison
si on doit s'arrêter
a uniquement à ça je pense que montigny
mérite plus que nous
la montée compte tenu de leur constance
que l'on appelle que l'on a pu donc
c'est juste à méditer pour le futur
à voir pour l'année prochaine à ne pas
reproduire les mêmes erreurs qu'on a
qu'on a fait cette année maintenant le
club tient pas uniquement est bon le
focus sur les seniors c'est bien mais
aujourd'hui on a une équipe jeune une
équipe et un entraîneur jeune
globalement la moyenne d'âge est
également très jeune donc le fo plaisir
tient pas uniquement sur son équipe
senior d'ailleurs le projet du club
c'est 700 licenciés mais c'était pas
comme enseignant aujourd'hui on a des
jeunes qui qui sont des très bons
résultats notamment les u17 qui risque
en croise edouard de monter en dhr on a
eu 15 du 19 17 qui sont aux demi finales
des coupes des yvelines que l'on
organise au mois de juin
donc tout ça c'est quand même hein c'est
quand même assez prometteur pour
l'avenir on a des maîtresses qui sont en
finale départementale qui ont bien
figuré puisqu'il termine derrière
derrière versailles et paris saint
germain
donc c'est le club ça ne tient pas
uniquement aux seniors si le club ne
vaut pas cette année ce ne sera pas une
catastrophe
donc nous on va on va maintenir nos
efforts notamment dans notre notre pré
formation et dans notre formation comme
on a l'habitude de faire puisque bon
juste il faut rappeler qu'il ya au-delà
qui est linguiste ans il ya aussi
christopher op ricains cassini
stagiaires pros stades manade caennais
donc on a un vivier de jeunes 700
licenciés c'est important et
et aujourd'hui l'intégration de des u19
en seniors c'est l'objectif principal du
club avec un staff jeune et de qualité
comme ça il ya aucune raison qu'à terme
on enrichissent pas à monter en
excellence départementale et donc le
projet du club c'est de pousser les
jeunes à aller vers les grands clubs je
pense notamment jean kévin augustin qui
est parti au psg qui est maintenant
troisième attaquant du psg ou garder ses
pépites et faire monter les équipes
justement voilà dans le dans le haut du
classement pourquoi pas au voir par
exemple plaisir en dh dans quelques
années c'est c'est le voeu pieux qu'on
sait tous mais en même temps on doit
absolument regarder l'intérêt de
l'enfant
l'intérêt du jeune intérieur
footballeurs du jeune footballeur et
donc nous on n'a pas l'ambition de
garder les jeunes pour les garder
l'ambition qu'on l'est d'ailleurs tous
les ans il y en a plein qui partent à
cette année on a eu une équipe u15 qui
qui joue la montée en dhr également dans
laquelle on sait on s'est fait prendre à
pas moins de quatre joueurs qui sont
partis à versailles à la cb donc notre
objectif c'est pas les garder pour les
garder l'objectif c'est de les garder
pour le faire progresser et
éventuellement des phares partir en
ligue six mois demain il ya des clubs de
lit qui viennent me voir pour me dire il
ya un tel qu'il peut plus celle en dh je
dirais boncourt on a fait un travail
c'est principalement pour ça qu'on est
con et missionné un mail coeur sur
l'équipe senior de plaisir si vous ne
montez pas ça sera l'argent quand même
malgré tout un petit peu quand même
parce qu'on a fourni les efforts courts
tout a été mis en place pour pouvoir
monter maintenant sur mon poste cette
année ses paroles ça sera pour l'année
prochaine
vous y croyez mathieu encore pour cette
année ça risque d'être très compliqué
voilà il faut deux faux pas de monter
donc sérieusement compliquée mais bon
c'est de bonne augure pour les
prochaines dont une équipe jeune merci à
tous les trois le passé sur ce plateau
bonne continuation à pour la suite on
passe maintenant à l'essentiel de
l'actualité sportive
un mot de gymnastique le championnat
dehimi des poussines et de catégorie à
libres 1 et 2 étaient réalisés tout au
long du week-end au palais des sports
d'el en cours pour de nombreux sportifs
présents ce championnat était le premier
de leur jeune carrière patrick jacques
de dixmude pour les images des barres
asymétriques des poutres cheval d'arçons
le palais des sports d'el hank ont
organisé ce week-end le championnat des
yvelines et poussines et des catégories
1 et 2 cette compétition est destiné aux
gymnastes débutants âgés de 7 à 15 ans
c'est très important
quel que soit le niveau de pratique
c'est important d'avoir des objectifs et
puis on doit montrer aux parents et à
leur encadrement leurs progrès et
d'avoir chacune leur pour nous au club
c'est très important de présenter toutes
ses catégories de gymnastes dans les
tribunes plus de 2000 spectateurs se
sont déplacés pour voir les athlètes
tout au long du week end
pas
sur les tapis l'événement attiré 9 cents
gymnastes venues d'une vingtaine de
clubs du département
le rendez vous était qualificatif pour
le championnat régional une compétition
organisée à la fin du mois de mai en
essonne sais pas si j'ai pas qualifiés
participer sérieux avec river
effectivement elles ne présentent pas au
port des éléments qui sont très
difficiles mais ce qui est important
c'est que ce qu'elles présentent soit
maîtrisé soit joli à regarder dans cette
compétition le jem et l'encours maurepas
à collecter trois médailles dont une en
or sur les épreuves par équipes
en individuel le club saint quentinois
remporté six médailles dont 3 en or on
continue par du football sont
d'entraînement de l'équipe de france
claire fontaine située dans les yvelines
à côté de rambouillet s'offre un lifting
à deux mois de l'euro 2016 un nouveau
bâtiment est inaugurée ce vendredi 8
avril en présence du secrétaire d'état
chargé des sports thierry braillard du
président de la fédération française de
football noël le graet la structure de
5200 mètres carrés abritera notamment la
direction technique nationale et centre
de conférences dans cette rénovation les
termes ont également été refait le
centre médical a été amélioré pour
l'euro on écoute didier deschamps le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
aujourd'hui en allée des terrains une
qualité de pose ou pelouse qui est
top niveau en terme d'hébergement on a
fait des aménagements aussi pour avoir
dans la salle
de vie au château une salle de
récupération une salle de musculation
qui complète ce qu'ils avaient avant
aujourd'hui les exigences du haut niveau
sont très élevés donc ça demande aussi
un amant est en préparation d'avoir des
infrastructures top niveau
l'euro devrait débuter en france le 10
juin prochain et tricolore devrait
s'installer dans leur camp de base le 5
juin
on passe au rugby en fédérale 3 les
joueurs de la cité royale sont sortis de
la zone de relégation après une victoire
contre vincennes le score 16 à 14
menés de 14 points au bout de dix
minutes de jeu les verse ayant su réagir
devant plus de 500 spectateurs
conséquence les bleus ne sont pas encore
enterré dans ce championnat ils
affronteront auxerre à l'extérieur
leader de la poule et qui compte 53
points de plus que les joueurs yvelinois
à match à quitte ou double en cas de
victoire versailles ce maintien en
fédérale 3 en cas de défaite il faudra
attendre les résultats des autres
relégable pour la mousson et vincennes
le président du club olivier nero 9
c'est que ce match est capital contre
auxerre ce sera très compliqué à pour
ses joueurs l'écoutent
c'est énorme énorme avec un budget qui
est de 705 150000 euros avec des
trentenaires dans la mairie qui sont
géorgiens roumains italiens écossais et
qui sont les rois du groupé pénétrant et
ne sont que des groupés pénétrants pour
tout est un des pénalités trouver des
touches pour faire des groupés
pénétrants est allé jusqu'à l'en-but
donc c'est très compliqué quand ton
équipe jeune et qu'on a pas dynamique
c'est très compliqué là devant leur
public ils pourront pas se permettre
d'avoir une moindre là où la moindre
défaite donc que mon avis ça va être
très compliqué un mot de judo à présent
une compétition était organisée ce
dimanche matin au centre sportif des
pyramides de voisins-le-bretonneux plus
de 120 judokas venus des essarts le roi
de cerner la ville de sacs les deux
voisins étaient présents pour
l'événement le vix sinois élise et roux
a remporté les poules dans la catégorie
benjamins louis reynaud s'est également
posé chez les benjamins chez les
poussins à lucas à noël a terminé 1er
adrien si on remporte les poux dans la
catégorie à minimes
on passe au basket trappe termine son
championnat par une bonne note les
trappistes se sont imposés à domicile
contre malakoff lors de la 22e journée
du championnat de nationale 3 score
final 77 à 70 au classement les saint
quentinois termine le championnat à la
6e place avec un bilan de 12 victoires
et 10 défaites
on referme ce magazine par deux
rendez-vous un rendez vous qu'il ne
faudra pas manquer 1 ce week-end en
baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux reçoivent
l'équipe fédérale de toulouse ce
dimanche à domicile pour leur premier
match de la saison du championnat de 2e
division
les y montrent un seront favoris ils
n'avaient pas fait de détails en
remportant leurs deux matchs deux
premiers matches de la saison 11 à 0 et
10 à 5 contre et sin début avril
on termine un parent du football
guyancourt 50.50 1 reçoit les mureaux en
match en retard du championnat
excellence hull et guyancourt toi compte
sur cette victoire pour s'emparer de la
deuxième place du classement devant le
ch est née la deuxième place pourrait
être synonyme de montée si l'aigu
courtois termine meilleur deuxième c'est
la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir suivi
on se retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine passé une excellente
semaine sportive très belle soirée sur
tv fil 78